so getting into the second part of our
discussion on Deadpool vs. Thanos
something that I really like about the
second issue is that it actually opens
up by giving us something that we
haven't really seen before the softer
side of Thanos and this section Thanos
is actually creating a letter to
mistress death by having his computer
record what he says the reason why I
like this so much is that throughout
Thanos publication history his actions
regarding life and mistress death
herself have always been shrouded by his
bravado and arrogance what I mean here
is that during stories like Infinity
Gauntlet his affections for death were
combined with his anger over the fact
that she wouldn't return his love at the
end of Thanos rising when he rejected
her after learning that she was
basically leading him on his actions
were again countered in anger
during this story and with death missing
and truth
Thanos is actually sad what he tells us
is that because she is absent from the
universe all forms of life are unable to
die whether it be diseases that are
curable through elimination or habitants
of planets which are destroyed when a
star goes supernova all of these
organisms continue to live on when they
should have died and as a result the
entire universe has been thrown into a
state of chaos
however this somber moment is
short-lived when Thanos expresses his
irritation that his deaths most loyal
subject when she vanished and sought
help for her freedom whether than Thanos
she called upon Wade Wilson at this
point we switch to Deadpool as he's
riding one of the outriders under Thanos
his command to sidetrack for a second
the outriders have appeared off and on
throughout the recent stories of Marvel
Comics but for their part the outriders
are more disposable than anything else
where they have intriguing abilities
like being able to turn themselves
invisible and alter the density of their
bodies to allow for flight and truth
they're basically cannon fodder but the
discussion between Thanos and Deadpool
reveals that when Thanos had monitored
waste discussion with mistress death she
had made reference to something called
the dwindling light now this is really
just an example of Thanos as vast and to
like coming out and that while it would
have seemed like a passing statement to
Deadpool or pretty much any of us to
Thanos it was actually a clue because he
spent most of his life traveling the
spaceways and is seen and done virtually
everything in terms of exploring the
cosmos the statement of mistress death
has led panels to believe that she was
referencing a mining colony on a moon
operated by the Shiar Empire which
received the nickname dwindling
right due to its proximity to a local
star now if you're interested in
learning more about the Shiar I have a
video on the race but during the events
of annihilation which saw a villain from
the antimatter universe called Annihilus
attemping to wipe out all life in the
main Marvel Universe by quite literally
using an army of bugs the mining colony
was basically abandoned with all
occupants either lost or leaving for
parts unknown now picking up on
dwindling light itself one of the funny
little quirks about this story is that
Thanos is wearing a spacesuit while this
isn't extremely important it adds to the
funny nature of the story and the Thanos
doesn't need to wear spacesuit but
seeing him in one is actually pretty
hilarious since he basically looks like
a giant teddy bear but what he tells us
is that his research led him to this
location following the clue of mistress
death but also because it was devoid of
life as such this place has been touched
by necromancy which is to say
individuals experimenting with death and
while Deadpool is instructed to keep
watch over the entrance and ensure their
safety he makes fun of Thanos for being
friend-zoned now in the comments section
of the last video some of you asked the
question as to why that hose would curse
Deadpool with immortality well what's
really cool here is that your question
actually gets answered when Deadpool
asks the same question as Denis explains
he simply just hates Deadpool more so
than that though for Wade and his life
was one of absolute misery what I mean
here is that when he originally
subjected himself to the Weapon X
program it was under the intention of
finding a cure for cancer and living at
a normal life however when the process
causes cancer to grow into abscesses all
along his skin there was no coming back
and the only thing Deadpool had truly
been looking forward to was his own
death what Tim Seeley is basically doing
here is telling us that once you get
past Deadpool's comedy and to the heart
of who he truly is Deadpool is simply
just a sad guy that wants to die and so
realizing this Thanos basically cursed
him with life and took away his ability
to die as a way to cause eternal torture
however in the midst of their
explorations the two were set upon by
the order of the glorious end now this
group as far as I know has been created
explicitly for this story and will never
actually see or hear from any of them
again but the order of the glorious end
exists as a group of cultists who
worship the idea of death when they
first arrived on the scene they
basically give us an explanation
as to who they are and why they're here
what we're told is that at some point
the group had begun to worship death
although we're not told why when Thanos
had picked up on the presence of death
at the mining colony this was basically
registering the act of the order of the
glourious and sacrificing half of their
number and never to call death to them
however when she arrived the result was
that she was basically kidnapped leading
to the situation as it exists now at the
same time 10 Sealy uses the history of
Thanos to tell us that because he spent
his whole life bringing death and
destruction down on various forms of
life he has an effect become deaths
Harbinger which means that wherever he
goes life will soon end and so
recognizing this fact and seeing that us
as a representation of death itself the
order of the glorious end stand down
allowing Thanos and Deadpool to continue
along their way now where Thanos his
actions were previously a bit ambiguous
we actually get a little more
information here because the order of
the glorious and worship the idea of
death and like Thanos himself wish to
join her realm because no one is
currently able to die he had promised
the cult that when mistress death is
restored to her rightful place he'll
return and murder them all during this
time though one of the members named
crystal had provided Deadpool her phone
number
and so before Thanos returns to kill the
order Deadpool's request as if Thanos
allows him to knock the boots with the
order member before she dies now what
happens next is actually one of my
favorite moments in the story because
that was experienced with passing on
provides him with an opportunity to see
death and receive clues as to her
location when the question is asked
where they should go next
Thanos responds by beating the life out
of Deadpool the reason why the reason
why I love this so much is because it's
funny to see that knows absolutely
pummeling Deadpool in order to both
learn what they can for mistress death
but also for the sheer joy of it however
in the midst of attacking wait the group
has suddenly met with the arrival of the
guardians of the galaxy in our last
video we had talked about how the
Guardians subdued one of the blood
brothers who had previously worked for
Thanos well the reason for this was due
to the fact that with danos and death so
closely intertwined due to his various
actions over the years and attempting to
gain her affections it made sense of the
guardians that if anyone were
responsible for eliminating everyone's
ability to die it would be Thanos as a
result their search for him led to the
mining colony due to the fact that Drax
a destroyer has the ability to
know exactly where Thanos is and the
cosmos something I'd also like you to
notice is that during the battle between
Thanos and the guardians Tim Seeley
actually makes a mistake here with
Rocket Raccoon being tasked with
ensuring that Deadpool is okay since the
Guardians don't fully realize everything
that's going on
when rocket meets Deadpool for the first
time and analyzes him using his wrist
computer the analysis states a Deadpool
is a mutant now Tim Seeley could have
been attempting a retcon here or you
could simply be pointing out to the idea
the Deadpool is a human mutate meaning a
human with powers but regardless I
thought this was something interesting
and simple just worth pointing out
however during the battle with the rest
of the guardians Rocket Raccoon fails to
understand everything that's going on
and as a result believes it Deadpool's
dead and so turning his back on Deadpool
he surprised when Wade comes back to
life and also calls for help from the
order of the glorious end now one of the
most common questions from Marvel Comics
fans is actually answered during a taunt
from Thanos aimed at Peter quill while
the Guardians have Thanos subdued and
attempt to learn about the situation
regarding why no one is dying
Thanos taunts quill in saying that the
number of times star-lord has died is
around 2 while Thanos has only died once
the only death of Stannis occur during
his early appearances prior to Infinity
Gauntlet with Marvel two-in-one annual
number two in 1977 when he fought Adam
warlock and was turned to stone because
quill has died more often than Thanos
this is really just a nose taking the
opportunity to talk pool event and at
the very least throw him off guard and
in the process provide a window for the
order of the glorious end intervene
taking the opportunity to make their
escape something that I actually thought
was pretty funny is a Deadpool asked for
a piggyback ride from Thanos to the ship
now the reason why I think this is
hilarious is because we never actually
see it happen and we simply just pick up
with a ship taking off and destroying
the guardians of the galaxy ship and so
if I were to be truthful here I'd like
to believe that Thanos provided Deadpool
with a piggyback ride because that would
be amazing
however once the two are on board
Francis who again in the last video had
been searching for Deadpool immediately
attacks him to add some context here
Francis and Deadpool
go way back originally Francis was one
of the attendings during Wade's time
under the web annexed project and with a
hatred developed between the two and
that Francis had actually tried to kill
Deadpool once Wade made it escape
and gathered his bearings he eventually
tracked Frances down and killed him now
while Frances made his return under the
name Ajax it became a main villain for
Deadpool under Joe Kelly's run for about
34 issues or so and Deadpool Volume one
issue number 19 Wade had killed him
permanently by snapping his neck but
with mistress death gone Ajax has
somehow reappeared and attacked Wade
under orders from his boss whose name is
not revealed and so as this section of
the story wraps up
Thanos steps in by knocking Ajax through
the hole of the ship and rescuing
Deadpool however during his experience
while dying on the surface of the mining
colony Deadpool was informed by mistress
death that they need to find the man
from Hell which seems to indicate that
they need Francis as his bosses likely
the person who engineered the kidnapping
of mistress death and caused this entire
situation
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end and let me
know what you guys think about this one
this one I think was a little lackluster
than the last one but it still had some
funny moments and with that being said I
will catch you guys on her purse